انقسام داخلي وكارثه خطيره اولى من نوعها
على وشك ان تحدث في صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي
هذا ما حذر منه رئيس المخابرات الاسرائيلي
ورئيس هيئه اركان الجيش مؤكدين لرئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو ان المضي قدما
بالتعديلات القضائيه سيؤدي الى نوع من
العصيان داخل المؤسسه العسكريه وبالتالي
تعريض امن اسرائيل للخطر
الخدمه العسكريه في الجيش هي قيمه عليا لن
يكون لدينا دوله بدون جيش ولا يوجد لدينا
دوله بدون جنود انتم تتجندون لحمايه
الدوله
وكان رؤساء الاجهزه الامنيه قد قيموا
الوضع بالخطير جدا وان رفض الخدمه
العسكريه بات خيارا ليس فقط لجنود
الاحتياط الذين انهوا خدمتهم العسكريه
انما ايضا لجنودا وقيادات وحتى عناصر من
المخابرات الاسرائيليه داخل الاجهزه
الامنيه
الخط الاحمر قريب جدا انا نفسي سوف اتوقف
عن التطوع وتقديم الخدمه للجيش في اللحظه
التي تمر فيها هذه القوانين وتخرج حيز
التنفيذ بالرغم من اطلاع نتنياهو على
خطوره الوضع الامني في ظل ازدياد اعداد
رافض الخدمه العسكريه خلال جلسه مغلقه مع
رئيس المخابرات ورئيس هيئه اركان الجيش
الا انه قد صرح بان حكومته لا تزال متمسكه
بالتعديلات القضائيه الشرح الخطير داخل
المؤسسه العسكريه الاسرائيليه سيؤدي الى
فقدان قوه الجيش الاسرائيلي وقدرته على
العمل في ظل وجود تهديدات امنيه خطيره
وتخوفات تتصاعد حول اندماج كل ساحات
الصراع في ساحه متفجره واحده لا نقول غاصي
من القدس العربيه